même si elle date à lyon se tiennent
aussi à paris avec la conférence rideau
amour la sécurité ne l'a fait contre le
terrorisme
je remercie tous les pays qui sont ici
présents près d'une trentaine
je salue également l'union européenne la
ligue arabe
le représentant spécial des nations
unies parce que c'est la communauté
internationale qui est aujourd'hui
présente à paris pour lire à cette
conférence a un seul objectif
apporter aux nouvelles autorités
irakiennes le soutien politique qui leur
est nécessaire pour lutter contre une
menace majeure qui s'appelle dash et qui
fait peser sur l'irak sur la région du
moyen-orient et sur le monde un risque
un risque majeur et le lâche assassinat
de david heinz en est une illustration
effrayante
s'il en était besoin ce groupe
terroriste a non seulement décapitées
des journalistes des humanitaires mais à
perpétrer des massacres des exactions
contre la population civile
ce mouvement terroriste s'en est pris
aux plus faibles aux plus fragiles aux
femmes aux enfants ce mouvement
terroriste s'en est pris également aux
minorités religieuses qui l'a pourchassé
pour éliminer un certain nombre de
communautés
ce mouvement terroriste s'est déployé
sur tout un territoire en irak en syrie
ce mouvement terroriste se joue des
frontières et prétend même fonder un
état
telle est la menace elle est globale il
doit donc y avoir une réponse globale
cette réponse doit venir des irakiens
eux-mêmes et c'est pourquoi je salue le
sens des responsabilités des nouvelles
autorités en irak qui ont su ouvrir le
dialogue
former un gouvernement d'union nationale
sous l'autorité du premier ministre
abadie
permettant le respect de chacune des
composantes du peuple irakien et
assurant ainsi son unité et sa
souveraineté
c'était la condition indispensable pour
rétablir la confiance et assurer le
rassemblement mais l'unité
elle est aussi nécessaire sur le plan
international le conseil de sécurité
dans sa résolution 2170 a déclaré que
dash constitue un danger immense pour la
sécurité du monde
le combat des irakiens contre les
terroristes et donc aussi le nôtre et
nous devons nous engager ensemble et
c'est le sens de cette conférence aux
côtés des autorités irakiennes
clairement loyalement et fortement et il
n'y a pas de temps à perdre
cette aide elle doit d'abord être
humanitaire près de deux millions de
personnes ont été déplacées et j'ai vu
moi-même
c'était vendredi à erbil la détresse de
celles et de ceux qui ont tout quitté
face à l'avancée des terroristes
pour ces familles pour ces femmes ces
enfants
nous devons engager un effort
exceptionnel
il faut mettre en place un véritable
pont humanitaire et renforcer l'action
remarquable d'ailleurs des nations unies
sur le terrain mais il convient d'être
efficace là aussi c'est le sens de cette
conférence recueillir des fonds des pays
amis acheminer les vivres et les
matériels indispensables et accueillir
dans la région et parfois au delà les
populations les plus menacées
l'irak a également besoin d'un appui
militaire
les amis d'irak doivent coordonner leurs
actions pour répondre aux demandes des
autorités irakiennes
la france pour sa part a déjà livré des
équipements en liaison avec l'europe et
les pays qui pouvait s'associer à nous
les etats unis ont agi
c'est le sens de l'initiative du
président obama de former une large
coalition pour lutter contre dash
beaucoup de pays y ont répondu
dans la région et au-delà et la france
il prendra sa part
mais le territoire urac irakien n'est
pas le seul concerné dash est installé
en syrie et menacent l'ensemble du
moyen-orient
il fait aussi appel ce mouvement
terroriste à des combattants venus du
monde entier et chaque pays y compris le
mien est concerné nous devons donc tout
faire pour lutter contre
l'endoctrinement de nos jeunes empêcher
leur embrigadement casser les filières
jihadistes et privés dash de ses
ressources et punir tous ceux qui lui
sont associés de près ou de loin en ce
moment même le parlement français débat
d'une loi qui justement veillera à
prévenir ses mouvements et à lutter
contre les filières et à punir les
responsables
la réponse à la menace terroriste est en
fac politiques et la communauté
internationale doit trouver une solution
durable
là où est né ce mouvement c'est à dire
en syrie je rappelle que depuis
maintenant trois ans la crise en syrie a
fait deux cent mille victimes deux cent
mille morts
le chaos fait le jeu des terroristes
il faut donc soutenir ceux qui peuvent
négocier et faire les compromis
nécessaires pour préserver l'avenir de
la syrie et pour la france ce sont les
forces de l'opposition démocratique
elles doivent être appuyées par tous les
moyens
et là encore la france il prend sa part
avec les partenaires régionaux qui ont
compris ce qui se jouait en syrie
je veux enfin alerté à l'occasion de
cette conférence sur l'urgente nécessité
de préserver l'unité et la souveraineté
du liban
car le liban accueille près de deux
millions de réfugiés syriens avec
l'arabie saoudite nous avons décidé la
france de soutenir l'armée libanaise
dans son effort d'équipement pour
assurer là encore la sécurité l'unité du
liban
je sais aussi que sous l'égide du
secrétaire général des nations unies le
groupe de soutien au liban coordonne
l'aide internationale en direction de ce
pays
je pense aussi à la jordanie qui doit
également bénéficier du soutien de la
communauté internationale
voilà notre l'ordre du jour de notre
conférence qui de prendre toutes les
dimensions de la solidarité que nous
devons apporter à l'irak soutien
politique aux nouvelles autorités
permettant la réconciliation et leur
rassemblement aide humanitaire pour
assurer protection et assistance aux
populations civiles et aux réfugiés
enfin la lutte contre des shs mouvement
terroriste qui n'exclut on le sait aucun
moyen et celle affaire de tous en tenant
cette conférence les pays qui sont
réunis ici font preuve de leur
solidarité à l'égard de l'irak et je les
en remercie
mais ils expriment aussi leur volonté
commune de se protéger contre le
terrorisme et d'agir en conséquence
et c'est pourquoi je vous remercie pour
votre présence qui fera de cette
conférence de paris
une étape importante dans la
mobilisation de la communauté
internationale pour l'irak et pour les
nouvelles autorités
et c'est pourquoi je salue ici une fois
encore la présence du président fouad
massoum
merci france 28 présent hollande y met
ce monsieur le président françois
hollande je voudrais vous saluer au nom
du peuple irakien au nom du gouvernement
irakien et en mon nom propre
permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
remercier et d'exprimer notre
considération au président françois
hollande président de la république
française à travers lui au gouvernement
et au peuple de la france et i am et et
d'exprimer notre reconnaissance pour cet
effort considérable que vous avez fait
et pour avoir répondu si rapidement à
notre demande à faire face à l'un des
défis les plus graves de notre époque à
savoir le défi terroristes merci à vous